.
Normand Grondin.
- Voici ce qu'il reste dndndndne
la marine marchande qui a sombré
dans le fleuve Saint-Laurent
en 1846. Une épave de 25 mètres
très bien conserv
par la noirceur et les eaux
glaciales du fleuve. Pour
un archélogue subaquatique,c'c'.
VINC
subaquatique, histoire maritime
- C'est comme un des derniers
témoins de la grande navigation
à voile, la navigation
on est au même moment où il y
a déjà les grands, les vap
qu'on voit jusque dans les
Grands Lacs, le développement
à prédominer, mais il reste
quelques navires com
un petit peu partout dans
le monde qui continuent de
faire des travprprprprprprprprpé
de riches marchands écossais
de Montr c c c coulé au large du
Bic, dans la région de Rimouski,
un jour de tempête.
d'équipage, ils avaient
deux chaloprprprprobablement.
Ils ont essayé de mettre les
chaloupes à la mer, les ont mist
qu'il coule, mais il y a eu
qu'un seul survivant.
a visité le Scotsman à
trois reprises depuis 20
en documentant tout ce qu'ils
ont découvert. L'objectif :
pour offrir une deuxième vie
au bateau, unetututututuelle.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS MALOUIN, prés.,
dir. crépepepepeper Splendide
- Le design qu'on a décidé
de faire avec l'application
de mettre les gens dans
ulululululiers des archéologues
subaquatiques.
- L'intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui de reproduire
les conditions dans lesquelles
travaillent les archéologues,
à 30 mètres de profondeur.
Une fois programmé, le casque
l'univers sous-marin de l'épave,
incluant la faune aquatiqu
Une des manettes servira de
lampe portative, l'autre de plan
détaillé de l'épav
Quatre utilisateurs pourront
temps.
- Les familles vont pouvoir
déambuler dans ce site-là
en murururururururururururururu,
ils vont être dans une salle
rsrsrsrsrsrs mètres carrés,
l'épave en regardant
avec leur lampe de poche.
- Un archéologue virtuel
la faune de l'épave découverts
par les apprentis plongeurs.
- C'est pour obliger les gens
à chercher, s'approcher,
regarder comme du monde.
Puis donc, être en con
avec les vestiges, puis en même
temps, se rendre compte que
c'est pas facile par
tu vois rien.
- Le Scotsman virtuel sera
intégré à l'exposition du Musée
marerererererererererererererer.
- Alors, ce qu'on fait c'est
sesesesesesesesesesesesesesesese
propre discipline qui est assez,
de photos,vavavavavavavavavavavs
continuer de faire, mais c'est
intéressant de les combiner
avec ces techniques-là.
l'offrir au réseau
de bibliothèques du Québ
- On a pas voulu faire quelque
chose de didactique, ou dessssss
ce que c'est d'être archéologue.
Ça va inciter des gens àrtrtrtre
tourner vers la science, s s s e
la science, c'est presque
Indiana Jones, là.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radioéaéaéa